For MSN News, I'm Candice Aviles.
Here's a new one for you.
A homeless man is 3,000 dollars richer today all because of his dancing moustache.
This man identified as Clydesdale...
...was captured by a prank group "whatever" making his moustache dance.
As you might have guessed, his moustache isn't actually dancing;...
...he is instead using his tongue to make it move.
After the video went viral, the group set up a donation page for Clydesdale.
The public responded to raise about 3,000 dollars for the homeless man.
How are you?
You've got to be kidding me.
No, I'd rather not.
I'm really speechless.
I don't know what to do.
I've got to go to my bank.
I think so.
We'll find a bank!
Many YouTube commenters applauded the group's gesture.
One commenter says, "That warmed my heart. You guys did a great job."
We wouldn't be surprised if this reminds you...
...of another YouTube field story of a homeless man.
Remember Ted Williams, the man with the golden voice?
When you're listening to nothing but the best of oldies,...
...you're listening to Magic 98.9.
The viral video led to job offers, talk show appearances and much, much more.
The Huffington Post reports Williams now has a job doing voice overs for Kraft Macaroni and Cheese.
In addition to the 3,000 dollars, the "whatever" group also gave Clydesdale...
...a hat, two shirts and a smoothie gift card.
Thanks for watching MSN News, I'm Candice Aviles.